so it's a new year of New Opportunities
and new challenges so in this video I'm
going to be breaking down the seven big
YouTube trends you need to know for 2024
this information is going to give you an
unfair Advantage this year and help you
protect yourself from some of the unique
dangers that we're facing in 2024 so
ultimately you can get more views grow
your following and earn more money as a
content creator or business owner
leveraging YouTube this year number one
high quality High effort long form
YouTube videos will continue to dominate
we've all seen it videos continue to get
longer on YouTube and we're seeing the
rise of connected TVs people are
watching in the US more YouTube than any
of the other Netflix or platforms on
their Smart TVs we're seeing one to 2
hour to three hour video podcasts and
some of the top creators are creating
videos that are upwards of 25 to 30 to
30 minutes plus in their average videos
and this makes sense because YouTube's
main desire is top time on platform we
always say minutes matter most and so
longer videos if they're good and they
keep people's attention are something
that YouTube loves and they reward you
as a creator with more reach with more
suggestions in the algorithm and with
more money number two short form video
will continue to grow in popularity
across platforms the most recent stats
reveal that YouTube shorts currently get
70 billion use every single day Tik Tok
is still a major Power Player and the
best performing content on meta
Instagram and Facebook is reals and is
vertical video and so short form
vertical video across platforms
continues to grow in popularity and I
think some of the predictions and trends
that we're going to see is we're going
to see cameras and video editing
software and AI that starts helping
content creators create more
multi-format content cuz I don't know
about you but in today's world I'm
sometimes a little bit frustrated trying
to think okay am I going to shoot this
vertical do I shoot this horizontal
should I actually shoot this wider so we
can crop in and do both I think we're
going to see tools supporting content
creators making it easier to create
content that can end up being
multi-format and to put it bluntly I
think that content creators that are
ignoring YouTube shorts are making a big
mistake but that's just my opinion
number three procreators will embrace
four plus content formats on YouTube
Here's the data 87% of adults are
watching at least four content formats
on YouTube shorts long form video
podcasts and live streams and 18 to 24
year olds have come to expect
multiformat with 67% of genzer saying
they like when their favorite creators
create content in multiple formats so I
don't blame you if you're thinking Sean
should I create long form videos or
YouTube shorts should I create a video
podcast or should I start going Live on
YouTube well my answer would be yes you
should do all of the above now one of
the things to clarify here is I said
procreators will Embrace four plus
content formats I think if you're just
getting started it's not necessarily
even practical to try to do it all but I
think that as you advance and maybe
systematize things learn better tools
maybe even start to build a team that's
when it starts to make sense to embrace
all these different content formats but
the Practical Point here is that
different audiences like to consume
content in different ways so if you're
not showing up in YouTube shorts you're
missing out on reaching people who love
YouTube shorts if you're not showing up
in longer form live streams or podcasts
where you can expound on your ideas or
create a deeper connection you're
potentially missing out on people who
prefer that content format and my
prediction is that YouTube is going to
continue to dominate multi-format really
dominating the podcast space dominating
the vertical video space and then of
course the foundation being high quality
high value High effort long form content
now today's episode is brought to you by
tube 1K challenge.com our next free
YouTube challenge for starting and
growing a channel this year is starting
soon but more on that later and you can
always check out the link and all the
show notes below let's dive into the
trends Trend number four AI will
continue to disrupt the Creator economy
now when it comes to AI we need to talk
about the good and the bad that is on
the horizon in 2024 so let's first start
with the good if you're not using AI as
a content creator you're making a big
mistake because there's so many
practical ways that AI can help you with
content creation I wrote down a list
script writing and brainstorming
automatic captions and transcripts video
editing quickly creating clips and short
form videos title generation thumbnail
generation and graphic design SEO
optimization social media management
content moderation and engaging with
your community there is no doubt that AI
can save you time help you make better
content and ultimately help you reach
your creator business goals faster and
another positive AI trend is hyper
personalization you know today's viewers
today's consumers they expect torade
experiences because there's all these
data points for example on YouTube
YouTube is looking at your watch History
which creators you subscribe to what
videos you like what videos you dislike
how you respond to different surveys
about content and what is your viewer
satisfaction and YouTube themselves have
Incorporated hyper personalization into
a new feature that's showing up on most
if not all Channel pages I don't know if
you've seen it yet but there's a for you
section at the top of our YouTube
channel homepages now this for you
section is selecting videos out of your
video library that whatever viewer is
landing on the page would be best for
them based on whatever metrics YouTube
is using so you don't have to do
anything to control this except for make
great content and build up a portfolio
and a body of work so that YouTube has
more quality content to recommend to the
unique unique preferences of viewers
landing on your page but again what
we're seeing is YouTube is already using
AI to incorporate hyper personalization
into the platform but there's also some
bad that comes along with AI that we
need to talk about so let's hit that
right now so by now it's no surprise
that there are many safety concerns when
it comes to AI deep fakes people's
voices sounding like them but saying
things they never said and YouTube has a
lot to say about this and I quote
generative AI has the potential to
unlock creat creativity on YouTube and
transform the experience for viewers and
creators on our platform but just as
important these opportunities must be
balanced with our responsibility to
protect the YouTube community so what
they've added and this will be rolling
out is disclosure requirements and new
content labels what's a Content label
well we've all seen now creators that
have a paid sponsorship in their video
the little pop out that says includes
paid sponsorship and so the YouTube's
goal is to avoid void misleading viewers
with a new disclosure that says altered
or synthetic content sound or visuals
were altered or generated digitally and
so the idea is that people will need to
check a box if they've used deep fakes
or they've used some kind of a voice
tool to create generative AI of
something that really didn't happen
YouTube goes on saying we'll require
creators to disclose when they they've
created or altered synthetic content
that is realistic including using AI
tools when creators upload content we
will have new options for them to select
to indicate that it contains realistic
altered or synthetic material my
prediction is that AI will be more
disruptive in 2024 than it was in 2023
and that year was insane so we have a
lot to look forward to and it's going to
get interesting Trend number five raw
and authentic content creators will eyes
to the top so one of the things we've
been seeing is a shift away from highly
produced forced content this is kind of
a reaction to the Mr
beastify of YouTube which simply means
always trying to outdo your last video
more spectacle more energy more noise
more fast-paced more trying to hack the
viewer brain to keep audience retention
as high as possible and what we're
seeing is creators having massive
success with really the opposite
approach to that Mr B style for example
if you haven't seen Sam silc yet he's
been one of the fastest growing creators
with an ultra stripped down minimal
editing basic thumbnails with no shine
to them they're even a little bit dingy
like a screen grab from the video
editing timeline and he's a 21-year-old
bodybuilder who as of March 2020 3 only
had 8,000 subscribers fast forward to
today and he's over
2.7 million subscribers he basically has
a vlog where he uploads every day and
again I think he is a refreshing
personality because he's real he's down
to earth kind of drives a normal car
he's tapping into the unbreakable cheat
code required to win on YouTube which is
consistency cuz he uploads every day but
he's paired that with authenticity he's
just real he's just raw and it just
feels different but his results have
been insane and one of the things that's
pretty surprising is that in
2023 the most looked up word on Miriam
Webster was the word authentic and so
people are craving real and I think
since the pandemic that we saw a lot of
lies told a lot of fake news a lot of
misinformation that there's a higher
level of skepticism than ever before and
so when things are overly polished and
they're overly flashy I think it can
sometimes raise up some red flags and so
there's a big opportunity for again this
kind of a different style of strip down
raw and authentic content creators now
I'm not saying that Mr BEAST's results
are going to suffer or that that style
of content is actually going to lose its
influence but what I am saying is
there's a big opportunity for you when
it comes to tapping into maybe a
different approach to YouTube than what
seems like the the only kind of content
that is working it's kind of anti
YouTube best practices not having all
the Flash not needing the perfect intro
or thumbnail not needing to outdo your
last insane video another example of
this is Dry Creek Wrangler school and so
in these videos Dwayne is like on a farm
he's on his property he's sitting in
front of his barn he like lights up a
cigar no cuts and he just shares wisdom
from his rich life experience the videos
have kind of a Solitude to them a
Tranquility to them and there's really a
genuine connection happening there and
so we're seeing short form videos that
are fast-paced kind of hacking dopamine
trying to just keep that energy going in
the YouTube shorts feed but we're also
seeing this anti-trend that I think is
something to pay attention to of sort of
a strip down opposite to that and I
think that for some creators they maybe
will Embrace both what if you uploaded
an anti- thumbnail like your thumbnails
look overly polished but she uploaded
one that's just a little bit more raw
like maybe the title's lowercase right
we've seen that and this isn't I don't
mean make this a tactic I just mean you
just kind of like let me get real with
you let me get raw with you let me just
talk to you and see how it goes because
Trend number five raw and authentic
creators will rise to the top number six
creators that last will focus on brand
building one of the mistakes a lot of
people make on YouTube is they chase
views and virality but they never build
an actual brand or connection with a
loyal audience I want to encourage you
don't just create content build a brand
don't just get views build your personal
brand and here's kind of what I mean if
you've ever consumed YouTube shorts
maybe whoever you love to follow I mean
and let me know I'll probably trigger
some people here but maybe you'll see
clips of Jordan Peterson or you see trip
clips of Andrew Tate or you'll see clips
of this president or that president or
someone reacting to them right who all
these different people that are building
their influence Elon Musk Clips well
when you see these clips whose brand is
being built Elon musk's brand is being
built and what account are those clips
on you have no brand Affinity you don't
know and even if you see long form
videos that are compilations of OPC
other people's content you know probably
being used by fair use but maybe not and
who knows what future Crackdown could
come here's the point whose brand is
being built in the process some of these
accounts that are getting views I don't
believe will be around in a couple years
because they never actually built a
loyal following with any kind of
affinity or connection to them it makes
me think about a vertical video that we
posted that just got a million views and
I've got a video podcast called the
think media podcast I'm interviewing
another guest and he tells a story about
another person named Rob dect now if you
love Rob you know he's a legend he's got
a lot of cool stuff that's happened and
this video pops off with him
telling a story about Rob dect whose
brand in that situation was built I
don't think my guest was I wasn't even
in the video really at all and I'm the
interviewer maybe the think media
podcast because its reputation of
bringing good information but really in
one sense it was a perpetuation of Rob
dared Dick's brand now I'm not saying
that newsjacking or Trend surfing or
influence surfing doesn't have its place
I'm just encouraging you to be
intentional about what brand are you
building which brings us to Trend number
seven but before we get there I have
four additional trends that didn't make
my top seven list but they're still very
important so stick around for those as
well as the biggest obstacles and
dangers that we're facing as content
creators so I'll be hitting those
towards the end of the video and as a
reminder today's episode is brought to
you by tube 1K challenge.com if you are
thinking about starting or wanting to
grow your YouTube channel this year and
get your first or next 1,000 subscribers
then definitely check out tube 1K
challenge.com 5 days Deep dive trainings
happening every single day we're giving
away cameras we're giving away a YouTube
studio and it's entirely free you can
hit the link in the YouTube description
to register but let's dive into the next
Trend number seven more creators will go
full-time this year than ever before a
recent article from Goldman Sachs
research revealed that the Creator
economy could approach a half a trillion
dollars by 2027 it means it's going to
double in the next 3 years so in other
words the next three years are going to
be the best three years on YouTube what
that means is that a lot of money is
flowing into the system and you need
money for your mission you need money to
do this full-time and a lot of that
money is Flowing to what's called micro
influencers and Nano influencers now a
micro influencer is someone with 10,000
subscribers up to 100,000 subscribers
but a nano influencer is someone with
1,000 to 10,000 subscribers and the
trend we're seeing is that brands that
are doing paid sponsorships are finding
better results and finding that they
prefer to work with micro and Nano
influencers now that doesn't mean that
A-list celebrities are going to stop
getting brand deals but basically the
idea is this instead of paying one
Superstar influencer $100,000 for a
sponsored video they can pay a 100 Nano
influencers $1,000 for hundred sponsored
videos and what they've discovered is
that these micro influencers have
authentic relationships with their
Community there's more engagement
there's more connection there and that
it's more work because you're working
with more people but that the brands are
getting better results in terms of
whatever their campaign objectives is
when it comes to influencer marketing
this means that if you learn the right
skills and you position your yourself
right you learn how to pitch you learn
how to connect with Brands there is a
lot of opportunity to go fulltime even
if you have a small audience however
there's a huge opportunity here that
almost nobody is talking about and that
is the rise of ugc creators let's talk
about it so the term ugc has been around
for a while and it stands for user
generated content this is when you have
a picture of you and your Stanley mug
and you tag the brand and they share it
or they DM you and ask can we post that
on our profile maybe you create a video
and they ask can we use this video on
our website and so that's what user
generated organic content is well
there's this new kind of content creator
called a ugc content creator and
essentially what they're doing is they
create content for brands that looks
real I mean it is real but it looks more
raw it looks like a a raw customer
testimonial but the difference is they
were actually paid by the brand to
create it the opportunity here is that
your YouTube channel is not being judged
by the amount of subscribers or the
amount of influence you have it's being
judged by your ability to create content
for the brand that they like maybe your
charisma the way you look your style
your humor and also your video editing
and storytelling and understanding maybe
of how to actually create content now
this might bring up this idea of well
are you being fake or just being paid to
lie and I think to do this with
Integrity is just the opportunity that
if there is a brand you love if there is
a particular product you love you could
pitch and reach out and again your pitch
will be different you're going to
position yourself of hey would you like
me to create content for your brand you
could use it in paid media you could use
it on your website you could use it in
these different places you getting
educated in this reveals that again
full-time might be a lot closer than you
imagined but it might look different
than you thought it was going to look
and that could be tapping into this idea
of ugc content creators let me know in
the comments if you'd like me to teach
deeper on this in the future and even
bring on some special guests to our
podcast because this is going to be a
major Trend and it's a huge opportunity
to generate money even if you are a
smaller Creator but let's hit these four
notable trends that didn't make my top
seven list but are still very important
number eight creators as consultants so
brands are increasingly hiring creators
for input into product development into
the creation of content for the brand on
their own channels and paid advertising
for speaking into their community and
speaking into their strategy what you
got to understand is that if you're deep
in this world you have a particular set
of knowledge and a particular set of
skills that brands just don't have and
while maybe new creators this isn't a
big opportunity it's happening for Mid
and larger creators at a crazy scale the
question for you is how could you
position yourself to be paid not for the
videos you create for a brand but for
your Consulting for your knowledge for
your skill set for your point of view
and for your experience creators as
consultants is a big Trend and it's
going to only continue to rise Trend
number nine is Creator packaged Goods
cpg so you've probably seen Mr BEAST's
chocolate bar his burger place maybe
Emer Chamberlain's coffee of course
Logan Paul and ksi's Prime well these
are Creator packaged goods and a trend
we've been seeing happen over the years
is creators launching new businesses the
new Creator might not be able to tap
into this but if you've created any
momentum you have a little bit of money
creators are funding startups there's
funding additional businesses outside of
the main thing that they're doing and
this is only going to continue to rise
in the coming years number 10 Creator
and audience values alignment here's the
stat 82% of Shoppers now demand that a
Brand's values align with their own you
know I'm recording this podcast in the
Pacific Northwest and if I go outside
there's a high likelihood that I will
see somebody driving a Subaru Outback
with a North Face jacket on sipping a
coffee out of their tumbler little
beanie hat on their way to hug a tree
that's a little bit of a stereotype but
it's pretty accurate and people in this
region love Brands like Patagonia why
because of the ethics of the brand the
values of their brand the impact that
they're committed to reduce their carbon
imprint uh imprint to recycle materials
and so people will even pay a premium
price for
products that aren't just good products
but also align with the values that they
have this applies to creators as well
and this was on my Trends list for last
year and I think it will continue how
can you weave in your values and your
beliefs and the things you stand for in
your content people don't just follow
people for the how-to information or the
entertainment they offer they really
connect with people with shared beliefs
and shared values and your mom may have
told you don't talk about religion or
politics at the dinner table and I'm not
saying those are the things that you
have to include in your content but the
data is in and especially with younger
Generations they are looking for values
alignment and I believe that the
creators who build stronger Brands and
don't just create content are going to
tap into the understanding of Creator
audience values alignment which brings
us to Trend number 11 which is SEO and
search will will enter a new frontier so
we need to start thinking outside of the
search box people are searching with
their voice people are searching with
text and images combined it's called
multi-search and so practically you
could consider using more conversational
long form questions when thinking about
search queries and keywords now this is
a macro Trend that's going to be across
platforms on search engines on things
like Google bard which is being used for
search combined with the information
they're giving you but on YouTube I
think about my habits after I get done
working most days a lot of times I'll
grab my Apple remote and I'll start
talking to it I'll say Hey Siri open up
YouTube and recently we bought a Toyota
Sequoia and we're about to go on a trip
over the mountains so we're now looking
for the Tuli roof racks that can have
some extra stuff cuz we got kids in the
car and we need extra space for the
journey well as I started to go down
that path of course I had to do some
research and now I'm overwhelmed I'm
like there's all kinds of different
sizes and what will fit and which one do
I want and YouTube is my go-to source
for that information but mostly when
searching I was actually talking to my
phone or talking to my Apple remote and
my TV I was doing voice search and so
this is something to look into that
search is evolving and that this is
going to apply not just to YouTube but
across platform AI is going to influence
this and so it's something we want to
keep close eyes on for how we can
benefit so we can rank position and get
our content discovered with some of
these new changes to search but when it
comes to Trends I think it's important
that we don't just look at some of the
opportunities but we also look at some
of the uncertainties and even dangers
that are just on the horizon for
2024 one is global events right now
we're living in geopolitical Conflict
Wars are happening supply chain
distributions are happening and so
there's going to be a lot of volatility
this year and I think that's something
to be aware of number two is the
possibility of economic recession this
affects consumers behavior their
spending habits most of these things for
Content creators become an opportunity
because people like watching free
content they like updated news about
global events but we need to be aware
that there could be certain things that
could affect our creator businesses
moving forward for example over the last
12 months brand deals have dried up for
some creators budgets have gone down and
AD spend because it's not just how these
things affect you it's how they affect
Brands and businesses and people around
you so we need to be awared for that the
third big thing we need to be prepared
for is it's going to be an election year
here in the US so you better believe
YouTube is going to be packed full of
all kinds of content related to this
what does this mean it means there's
going to be an heightened interest in
news and politics it means that if
you're in anything related to that or
you even tie your content into the
election there's new audiences to reach
it means there's going to be Lively
conversations and debates and maybe you
can expect people being on edge in your
comments or being mad maybe not at you
they're just mad at the world they're
mad at whoever's candidate is winning
they're mad in general things will get
in they might get a little edgy it means
that there's going to be combating of
misinformation we already talked about
AI but there's going to be probably a
ton of misinformation there's going to
be a ton of drama because of AI because
of what we've already seen in previous
election years there's going to be a lot
of campaign advertising YouTube ads ads
across platforms you'll probably see a
lot of campaign ads in front of videos
that might raise your revenue and
there's something about positioning
yourself because tons of money billions
of dollars will be spent on average
advertising this year uh there's going
to be demonetization risks one expert
said platforms may be more cautious
about content deemed politically
controversial potentially leading to
demonetization or shadowbanning of some
creators there could be shifting brand
Partnerships Brands might be hesitant to
associate with creators perceived as
taking strong political stances
affecting existing Partnerships or
influencing future collaborations and
you might feel pressure to remain
neutral some creators May face pressure
to stay neutral to avoid alienating
potential viewers While others may
choose to embrace their political views
and cater to a niche audience and so
back to values alignment I think you
could go political or you could not go
that direction and it actually might
give you an advantage or it may cause
you to have some loss that could lead to
other gain but no doubt about it the
election year is going to be very
interesting as it pertains to something
to prepare for and I think number four
really sums up these uncertainties and
here's the trend the never normal you
know a while back we heard the new
normal during the pandemic we're getting
back to the new normal well here's what
experts are predicting the continuous
now Evolution turbulence instability one
crisis after another and I think just
the connectedness of the world we just
are aware of everything that's happening
that the new state of being is this idea
of the never normal and so what does
this mean for you and how can you best
prepare to win and succeed on YouTube
and Beyond in 2024 I've got one big idea
to go a little bit deeper on but I do
want to pass the question off to you
especially if you watch the podcast on
YouTube what are your predictions for
2024 which Trends do you want to tap
into that I mentioned what are some
other Trends you're noticing and also
what is your biggest challenge when it
comes to YouTube and your creator
economy business I'm committed to
helping you win on YouTube all year long
and creating the best content possible
for you so I'd love to know some of your
questions or your challenges if you
listen on audio maybe head over to the
video version because I'm going to be
spending a lot of time in the comments
connecting and listening to your point
of view and some of the things that you
need but here is the big prescription
and the secret to success in 2024 that I
believe and I already mentioned it
here's the word agility agility means
responding faster to any situation and
as you listen to this podcast you might
be thinking I'm kind of stressed I'm
kind of anxious like it feels like the
target's always moving like YouTube's
always changing like the world is always
changing almost like things are never
normal welcome to 2024 we need agility
this might mean replacing your Five-Year
Plan with a fluid approach and the
willingness to do micro pivots it's
always good to have a long-term vision
in mind but understanding that the path
to get there will not be a straight line
and so sometimes when short form content
is growing or maybe you are romantic you
love the length of videos you make or
the style of videos you make but as
things change they are inviting you to
adapt and pivot quickly and I really
believe that in 2024 the content
creators that are going to not just
survive but also Thrive they're really
going to embrace adaptability they're
going to skill up faster they're going
to outwork out learn out strategize and
Outlast other creators because they
adapt quicker they reinvent themselves
quicker they think about their brand and
they pivot to changes in the market
faster adapting to the never normal with
agility and micro pivots will ensure
that you are a part of the realtime
conversations that are happening and
that you're not chasing after them and
getting left behind if you enjoyed this
content and want to take your YouTube
channel to the next level just click or
tap the link on the screen or go to tube
1K challenge.com to join our next live
YouTube challenge you'll learn our best
tips and strategies that are working
here at think media and I think you'll
love it